Kobe Bryant's legacy lives on even in a galaxy
far, far away.
On Sunday, January 26, 2020, the former Los
Angeles Lakers player, husband, and father
of four died at the age of 41 in a helicopter
crash.
The aircraft which was carrying Bryant, his
13-year-old daughter Gianna, and seven other
individuals, including the pilot is said to
have been flying through inclement, foggy
weather conditions, which may have contributed
to the fatal wreck.
Bryant left behind his wife, Vanessa, and
three other daughters.
In the wake of Bryant's death, fans have posted
online countless tributes to him, remembering
Bryant for the person he was on and off the
court.
During that remembrance, Star Wars enthusiasts
have recalled Bryant's connection to the hallowed
property: there's a character that was actually
inspired by him.
"Welcome to the Kobe show.
Take two."
The Kobe Bryant-inspired Star Wars character
is a droid named K2-B4 a reference to both
Bryant's initials and his number 24 Los Angeles
Lakers jersey, which he began wearing during
the 2006-07 NBA season after changing from
his old number 8 jersey.
K2-B4 appeared on three episodes of the third
season of the animated series Star Wars: The
Clone Wars, which takes place in the three
years between the Star Wars prequel movies
Attack of the Clones and Revenge of the Sith.
A feminine character who uses "she/her" pronouns,
K2-B4 also sports a yellow and purple color
scheme the same palette that the Lakers use.
According to StarWars.com, at the time the
Clone Wars animation department created K2-B4's
animation model, the Lakers had won the NBA
Championship.
It's also been said that the inclusion of
K2-B4 on the series was a nod to crew members
who were Lakers fans.
A T-series tactical droid, K2-B4 served the
Confederacy of Independent Systems.
Her biography details that she experienced
a lot.
She entered Lola Sayu, the planet containing
the Citadel, without being detected; she got
briefly tricked by battle droids transporting
R2-D2, resulting in her altering Citadel guards
to capture the droids; and she boarded a Lucrehulk
Droid Control Ship but unfortunately failed
to keep a group of Jedi masters out of Lola
Sayu.
If only K2-B4's win rate was as good as Kobe
Bryant's!
As it happens, Kobe Bryant's ties to the Star
Wars property extend even further than K2-B4.
To announce his then-impending retirement
from the NBA which came after the 2015-16
basketball season Bryant penned a poem entitled
"Dear Basketball," in which he discussed his
love for and dedication to the sport.
Bryant eventually partnered with animator
and character designer Glen Keane, who has
credits in films like Aladdin, Beauty and
the Beast, and The Little Mermaid, to turn
"Dear Basketball" into an animated short film.
"I'll always be that kid with the rolled up
socks, garbage can in the corner, five seconds
on the clock, ball in my hands."
With Keane animating and directing and Bryant
narrating from the poem he wrote, the biggest
thing left to do was find someone to score
the short.
The person they settled on was none other
than John Williams, the legendary composer
who's scored the films in the Star Wars franchise.
What's even more interesting is that "Dear
Basketball" went on to win the Oscar for Best
Animated Short Film at the 2018 Academy Awards
ceremony, and Star Wars actors Mark Hamill,
Oscar Isaac, and Kelly Marie Tran presented
Bryant and Keane with the shiny golden statue.
Fans may even recall that Bryant walked onto
the basketball court to the infamous "Imperial
March" from Star Wars in December 2013 after
recovering from an Achilles tendon injury
that threatened to end his NBA career.
He also once compared himself to the franchise's
most notorious villain, telling ESPN's Baxter
Holmes in December 2015 that he sees himself
as, quote, "Darth Vader, of course."
With a smile, Bryant added:
"But I don't take orders from the Emperor...so...Darth
Emperor, maybe."
"Darth Emperor" doesn't have quite the same
ring to it as his famous nickname "Black Mamba"
does, but no matter what you call him, Kobe
Bryant will always have a place in the Star
Wars universe.
"Heroes come and go."
"But legends are forever."